the Chimera in Greek mythology the
Chimera is a monster with the body and
head of a lion a snake for a tail and a
fire-breathing goat head protruding from
its back the appearance of the Chimera
can vary there are versions where it has
the hind legs of a goat with wings and
even the head of a dragon sibling to the
Hydra and servers much like many of the
other monsters in Greek mythology the
Chimera is the daughter of Typhon and
echidna the mere sight of the Chimera
was considered a bad omen as the monster
would often appear before natural
disasters such as violent storms and
volcanic eruptions the Chimera took
residence in Licio and for many years
terrorized the neighboring towns and
villages in fear for his kingdom king
low with us turned to bella la throne
the son of Poseidon to aid him and
destroying the Beast once he accepted
the cause of his king Bella Lefranc
consulted with the soothsayer Politis
who advised him to seek help from the
winged horse Pegasus in order to do this
bola front would have to spend the night
in the temple of Minerva as he slept
Minerva came to him and gave him a
golden bridle when he awoke Minerva took
him to Pegasus and at the sight of the
golden bridle the steed came willingly
to aid him bellow the front mounted
Pegasus and they took to the skies and
searched for the Chimera flying above
the Chimera bell Allah from was able to
rain down arrows upon the creature his
efforts were in vain as the Chimera was
able to melt his arrowheads before they
made any contact the Chimera began to
overpower bell Olaf run and he steed
with the sheer power of its fiery breath
Bellerophon had the idea of attaching a
lump of lead to the point of his spear
and thrusting it in between the jaws of
the Chimera
the creatures fiery breath melted the
lead which trickled down its throat burn
in its insights instantly killing the
Beast many believe that the Chimera
is a symbol of the volcano located in
Licio the surrounding area was known for
its constant burning fires hence the
name mount chimera if you've enjoyed
this video then please consider leaving
a thumbs up as it helps promote the
video and allows the channel to grow if
there's anything you'd like to discuss
or have any ideas for future videos then
please let me know in the comment
section as always I've been your host
mythology and folklore explain